thank you see how many Michigan faculty
can we get here so I'm going to talk
about something really very different
from the other talks in this workshop
and I'm going to talk about sort of I'm
gonna talk about a data problem and sort
of assumes that you've collected a bunch
of data whether they're you know auction
data or network data and before you can
begin to do anything you need to do some
cleaning some repair etc and so the joke
title is if it ain't broke don't fix it
so this is how do you how do you clean
up your data so that you ensure that it
is a metric okay so here's the setup of
the problem I'm gonna take a matrix D a
symmetric matrix that's n by n all the
entries are non-negative and this is
said to be a metric if the entries on
the diagonal are zero and if the entries
that come in triples satisfy the
triangle inequality ie D is a collection
of data points at all satisfied
properties of a metric and I'm gonna
rewrite the idea of all these distances
satisfy triangle inequality I'm gonna
rewrite them as a system of inequalities
and then you can stuff all of the
conditions on D into a nice matrix M and
you can vectorize D turn into a great
big long vector and you can rewrite all
of these conditions as saying some nice
structured matrix M times the vector
form of da should be entry wise greater
than or equal to zero okay and so each
row of M corresponds to a triangle
IJ K and to say that all the distances
satisfy a triangle inequality means that
you've got this nice structured matrix
if you also wish to be pedantic and put
in all of the conditions like the
distances must be greater than or equal
to zero then stack in the identity
and to em as well but you know let's not
be completely pedantic let's focus on
the one I really care about is the
triangle inequality okay so here's the
here's the the motivation the set up of
the problem you know we've collected
data we've worked with our social
science friends our colleagues and they
have told us yes this is real data and
you know I'm going to derive some kind
of similarity measure from this data or
its location data and it's supposed to
satisfy a metric you know if it's
location data why I really should
satisfy a metric because it's you know
it's in space and you know when your
data come from a metric then all kinds
of other algorithms get much much easier
so you can run you know downstream all
kinds of nice unsupervised machine
learning algorithms you know for example
clustering lots of approximation
algorithms give better guarantees when
your data come from a metric there are
applications and computer vision and in
bioinformatics like amino acid
substitution matrices that are used and
alignment problems okay so how do we
ensure that the data that our colleagues
give us or the data that we collect
really satisfies a metric I mean in
particular anytime you work with real
data it's messy it's horrible censors
crap out you get noise you know things
things are a mess okay so but you know
all of the world is set up for this
beautiful situation how do i how do I
clean things up ok so formally I would
like to given a set of distances or you
know given a similarity matrix
I would like to ensure that the matrix
that I operate on on my downstream
algorithms I would like to ensure that
that data really does come from a metric
so I'm going to assume that I
given some corrupted metric d-prime ie
some triangle inequality is broken and I
would like to find a perturbation P so
that D prime plus P is a metric in other
words find P such that M times D prime
plus P is then greater than or equal to
zero entry wise ok and if you would
really insist on being pedantic you know
you've got to clean up and so that I
ensure that everything in here really
satisfies a a proper distance things are
non-negative ok so here I like to think
D prime is the corruption of some metric
D and P is the repair okay everybody got
that yeah yes ok yes there are lots of
ways to do this I would like to make
this as small as possible actually so
there are a whole bunch of different
ways to do this so I'm going to do this
in sort of revisionist history order so
I started thinking about this from an
old paper of brickle Dylan and Trop
about 2007 2004 and they say no let's
find a perturbation that you know
basically we want to take our corrupted
matrix and project onto the subspace of
metrics ie find the new metric that is
as close as possible in the Frobenius
norm to the original ok so then that
sounds small ok you could ask instead to
return a metric that really isn't truly
is euclidean and there's a huge history
you know much older bunch of work in
this area you know extensive work on
this and the psychometric literature you
know you could view multi-dimensional
scaling as a version of this find me the
closest euclidean distance matrix to my
corrupted my corrupted distance ok so
this is another sense in which you know
I want to be close
okay yeah I don't really like these
solutions though because they preserve
they perturb most of my original
distances in other words I have to I
have to touch like all of my original
data to clean things up and I don't I
don't really like that I would prefer to
take a more optimistic approach and
assume that most of my original
distances are correct and actually just
a few of the distances are corrupted you
know if I collect data a few of my
sensors are noisy but all the rest of
them are pretty good I don't want to
have to you know this somehow it feels
like seriously distorting the all of the
original data I collect I want a more
optimistic approach in other words I
would like to repair as few of the
original distances as possible so that's
what I mean by don't touch too many of
them have this be small so I would like
to minimize the l0 norm of my
perturbation this l0 norm it's a it's
not a norm and be all it's doing is
counting how many nonzero entries there
are in my perturbation in other words
how many of my original distances do I
have to correct to ensure that the new
distance matrix satisfies a metric
everybody get this this is sparse matrix
repair make as few sparse metric repair
make as few changes as possible to
ensure that your new data satisfies a
metric okay so you know if one is not
looking too carefully at this slide and
zooms in on this l0 norm and that's not
a norm it's not convex I can't deal with
this problem maybe I could convexity
this norm and make this an l1 norm so
that's a pretty nice standard thing to
do except I'm going to tell you
empirically it doesn't work as well as
one would think so the naive convex
relaxation does not give you the sparsa
solutions in general and
if you're really thinking
combinatorially you'll notice this
matrix em it's tall and thin it's not
short and fat so your standard like
compress sensing machinery doesn't work
so M is over determined furthermore if
you think about you know where all these
plus minus ones are in M it's very
structured it's definitely not random
and it's fairly and it's fairly coherent
ok so this doesn't work very well yes oh
yeah that's actually a good question
yeah yes so essentially you're asking
for this bar so this point in a polytope
and it's a very special polytope all
right so I'm gonna give you a little bit
of the story ahead of time about the
experiments like what one would try
first and then tell you it doesn't work
so well and then I'm gonna tell you you
should really address this problem more
combinatorially okay so I'm going to
keep moving I I have like 15 more
minutes okay and I can talk fast all
right so one could try re weighted L one
right instead of just straightforward
one you could try to re weighted L one
it's actually works incredibly well
although you know and it is connected to
finding sparse points in polytopes so
actually thinking about geometrically
what it is you're doing this is this
gives you a good a good algorithm I
can't analyze it at all okay no okay so
let's get to some technical stuff enough
with these experiments so the real
problem with convex methods possibly a
problem is that there n cubed
constraints that come from each of these
triangle inequalities solving large LPS
is expensive I'd really want to exploit
the combinatorial nature of this problem
I mean come on they're triangles could
we possibly this is a naive question
could we possibly efficiently detect
whether or not our data is
a metric could we find the broken
triangles quickly Matt probably not
okay so there's nice result from 2010
saying the by Williams and Williams the
following weighted problems either all
have truly sub cubic algorithms or none
of them do and right here in the middle
is checking whether or not a given
matrix satisfies a metric so we probably
can't do better than n cubed time so I'm
going to give up on faster than n cubed
time but I'm not going to give up on
exploring the combinatorial nature of
these problems because you know M is so
structured it's so nice it's this is not
a general polytope there's something
really beautiful in here and so in order
to exploit the combinatorial structure I
want you to think for a bit about all of
the different scenarios we could have
for our repairs let's break this problem
down into pieces and see if we can
tackle each piece so the first one we're
going to call decrease only metric
repair in other words our perturbations
should only shrink distances that are
wrong and so here's this triangle one
two seven and the correct fix should be
to shrink seven and we get a proper
triangle we could do something else with
the same triangle one two seven we could
do an increase only metric repair in
other words we we constrain ourselves to
only increasing distances that we think
are incorrect so change the one there to
a five to make a proper a proper
triangle okay and notice it's the same
triangle one two seven a sparse decrease
only metric repair solution is not
necessarily the same as the sparse
increase only metric repair salut
and furthermore I mean in this example
the sparsity is one for each one but
that need not be the case in more
general situations so we should consider
these two situations separately where we
are allowed only to decrease where we
are allowed only to increase and then
there's the general situation where we
don't we where we don't place any
restrictions on our perturbation one to
seven could go to four to five okay all
right now I claim that there's a really
beautiful simple algorithm for decrease
only metric repair and those of you who
have to teach undergraduate algorithms
if you squint at this you'll say I've
taught this I know this this is simply
the floyd-warshall algorithm for all
pair shortest paths this fixes the
distances that are incorrect and it
fixes them only by when you're only
allowed to shrink distances and so in
particular you can go through this and
check sure enough the what is returned D
hat the correction is the all pair
shortest path solution for the complete
graph on n vertices with the weights
given by the original distances okay
I'll let you think for a second why all
pair shortest paths should be the right
thing to do
you know look when I go to fix seven
it's too big the best thing I should do
is use the shortest path between I and J
and that's three okay so you can
actually prove a nice result that all
pair shortest path algorithm is the same
as the sorry this problem all pair
shortest paths is the same problem as
decrease only metric repair and this was
noticed a little bit in this original
paper by Brickell they noticed that
they had an algorithm that they observed
was the same as the floyd-warshall
solution and they noticed elementwise
what you returned was no bigger than the
old pair shortest past solution and then
what my postdoc let Jane and I showed is
that in fact actually that is the spar
cyst possible decrease only metric
repair and in fact you can also show
that it is the closest in l1 norm which
is kind of cute
a beautiful combinatorial algorithm that
gives you the effect a well-known coming
it's simple combinatorial algorithm
gives you the closest repair and l1 norm
and it's also this bar system you could
if you had access to an Oracle you had
some idea of which sensors were flaky
ahead of time or you had some idea some
suspicions about your data you could
come up with an algorithm that uses
Oracle information that runs faster than
n cubed of course you need the Oracle
information ok increase only metric
repair is as a fascinating version of
the problem and what makes increase only
metric repair differ and harder from
decrease only is that you can't figure
out which leg of the triangle you should
fix so in particular if you've got d IJ
is greater than the sum di k plus d JK
you can't figure out which one of these
should you increase so as to fix this
inequality make it turn the other way
around so you know either one of these
could have been initially perturbed and
you can't figure out which one to pick B
hmm you could flip coins you could
decide only to do one and the second I'm
going to tell you if you decide only to
do one that's not a bad algorithm
and then I'm going to point out that if
your intuition if your inclination is to
use some kind of l1 minimization it's
not so good
because there are many possible l1
solutions but few of them are sparse so
in particular I have an infinite family
of solutions for just this simple stupid
little triangle they all have a total l1
norm fix of four and there's an infinite
number of them you know increase one by
X and increase two by four minus X okay
and I you know the total l1 norm here is
four I cannot distinguish you know any
of them from one another and it's just
one simple triangle okay so that
suggests we should do something like
arbitrarily always pick one of the two
trying one of the two legs of the
triangles that's messed up and just fix
that okay so in particular here it's
either this leg or this leg that I
should fix
let me always pick the the one here
that's on the left fix that one and
return that solution okay so we're gonna
call this increase only metric repair
IOM are it's actually not too bad
so this silly idea returns a
perturbation that is guaranteed
well it's guaranteed to produce a
correct solution I guess that's good
you're guaranteed that you're a RIT that
you're fixed that your repair is a
metric okay great that's a good thing
okay how can I possibly interpret these
these solutions we don't know you know
[Music]
we can start to formulate ideas about
the sparsity of this solution so in
particular my student Rishi
so Talia has kind of bad news he can
cook up a gadget for every end he can
cook up a corrupted input matrix D Prime
for every value of n such that the
approximation ratio is roughly order n
between iõm R and and the optimal
solution so you know this is a very
particular gadget it also depends very
strongly on the fact that IO mr fixes
distances in in particular order it goes
in lexicographic order and so he uses
that to build his gadget however you
know this is a worst-case guarantee okay
so he's busy working on on other
interpretations of Io mr I don't want to
give it away too many too many results
from last week okay anyway I owe Mr in
and of itself as a fascinating as a
fascinating set up okay you can also
incorporate Oracle information into IO
mr again if you have some idea
information ahead of time as to which
triangles are broken or possibly
possibly broken and I'm gonna skip over
this this algorithm it basically uses an
Oracle to give upper bounds on the true
value of the distances and then uses
decrease only metric repair to fix those
values that you that you have that you
know to be wrong and you can guarantee
that if you have an Oracle then i ôm r
has sparsity equal to the sparsity of
the Oracle which is kind of nice if you
have a good idea of what's broken then
you're not repairing anything more than
than what you thought ahead of time with
okay you can come up with a similar
heuristic for the general metric repair
problem I'm not gonna write down I'm not
gonna write down the algorithm I can't
say anything really about about the
general metric repair heuristic you know
we can we can write down the algorithm
we can we can run experiments we don't
have too much that we can say
theoretically yet okay so I'm giving you
this talk now in the proper order Theory
first and then experiments
I began by describing the experiments a
summary of the experiments ahead of time
to motivate what we can and cannot say
in theory now I will give you a proper
discussion of all of the experiments and
they point to yet more interesting
theory to be done and so the last time I
gave this talk it was to an audience
full of mathematicians who understood
the problem so easily because it's so
simple and I got a zillion ideas about
experiments so I'm gonna tell you ahead
of time these are these these are
limited experiments and I know that
there are many more we could do so we
had we focused on increased only metric
repair and our heuristic algorithm for
the general problem and then you know
convex optimization methods because it's
fun to compare we did not run any
experiments on decrease only metric
repair because I didn't particularly
want to test floyd-warshall on graphs I
thought that was a fairly well
understood algorithm by now so the kinds
of metric spaces the kinds of data that
we cooked up Euclidean we took you know
random points in Euclidean space and
either perturb to them in positive and
negative ways or negative only we cooked
up air - ranee random grass
and took the path metric on random
graphs and you know again either
negative or arbitrary perturbations and
then because we knew that all pair
shortest path algorithms behave behave
differently on random data we took
random symmetric matrices and repaired
them we fixed them changed them into
proper metrics um I will say that if you
think for a second about how to set up
these experiments you'll see how you
know there's gotta be some thought that
goes into by how much do you perturb
things so to 'print e that you that you
have broken triangles to fix what kind
of parameter settings should you use for
your random graphs to have different
kinds of graphs to have different kinds
of distances or diameters or you know
connectivity if you will on your graph
so you know it takes a little bit of
thought even to cook up the right sort
of experiments and then to evaluate our
our algorithms you know we could have
done a zillion things we just focused on
the sparsity of the output and then the
run time so that's all I'm going to show
you and I will be quick with my
experiments I'm gonna tell you let me
skip this slide is about the general
algorithm the for the heuristic
algorithm for the general problem
it works mostly okay okay yeah it works
mostly with interesting is that it left
a very small fraction of triangles
broken so fewer than 1% broken in the
end and iteratively re-weighted l1 does
beautifully l1 minimization less well
than the heuristics at some
in between then the funny thing is when
we went to repair broken triangles on
air - rainy random graphs we actually
repaired fewer than were originally
perturbed in other words we were fixing
things that had not been disturbed
originally but fixing things in such a
way as to ensure that we had a metric
it's kind of interesting
here's the here's the identity saying
this is you know if you had the exact
sparsity of what was perturbed and so
we're actually fixing fewer than what
was originally perturbed and I can't
explain this behavior okay here's the
performance for uniform uniformly
sampled random symmetric matrices where
you know roughly 50% of the triangles
are broken and the heuristic does really
well
l1 minimization less well here is
roughly 50% so you know a few quick
observations the results really strongly
depend on what metric it is that you
start with in the first place
[Music]
the non convex optimization methods so
using combinatorial knowledge of the
problem gives you an algorithm gives you
algorithms that are hundreds of times
faster although not beating any you know
cubic barriers just in in practice on
problems of this size the the convex
optimization methods which were general
purpose tools were much slower so what's
next so you know my mission is is busy
working on studying the ins and outs of
increase only metric repair I think this
is kind of interesting these lots of
graph algorithms can be expressed as
linear programs you know they turn their
dual programs and
turn into efficient combinatorial
algorithms and we've proposed a bunch of
combinatorial algorithms for what are
essentially graph algorithms so what is
the corresponding dual program what is
the corresponding linear program and one
application area that we're we're
working on but is not anything to do
with sort of computational social
science is clustering genomics data and
then this is my my plug these problems
when these algorithms are really
different from sort of a decade's worth
of sparse analysis problems and I think
it's worth having that mindset but it's
worth keeping an open mind when it comes
to new problems does it become easier or
harder we haven't tried that Eric I'm
almost certain that you can I'm asked
Rishi to do that and he's in the that is
of course one of the things I asked him
first so he's working on it almost
certainly I can't tell you how much
better maybe a random sample maybe just
a worst-case sample and and and now you
want to do everything that you did but
but saying that that's just a sample
piece yes I have also asked me that so
like I said he's in the middle of
working on this stuff I said ah what if
you increase only metric repair as you
know those zeroes are missing data how
well does it do to fill them in how well
does IOM are do to fill them in and and
to do the comparison with there's a body
of literature called matrix completion
so do the comparison
this is about the incorrectness and the
TV you do have not in the missing leader
okay
we haven't done that yet right so you're
saying what if I not only do I have
missing data but I also have incorrect
data yeah we have willing to take the
samples odd I'm gonna think about the
things I don't know about they're gonna
be matrix completion but but even so
given that it's viewed as being sampled
from the poll so it's not just a full
page equation probably not revealing
yeah so so we haven't done that I mean
you notice I said I was I was upfront
the evaluation metrics that we've used
for the experiments we've done thus far
or just these two not how by how much
did we correct two things that were you
know by by how much in value we just
looked at how many things did we fix so
you know the answer no we haven't done
that yet we did that apology
um so I'm not sure I mean I'm not sure
what you're asking me so there are these
two there are these two very traditional
methods no these just fix not for doing
detection so the Williams and Williams
result says detecting is just as hard as
all pair shortest paths so maybe you can
do detection you know in a probabilistic
sense but if you want it exact probably
not I don't know we actually kind of
punted on the detection part okay more
questions
[Applause]